[موسيقى]
مواسم العرب تنقسم الى قسمين مواسم
امتزاجيه هو مواسم انفصاليه الانفصاليه هي
الفاصله بين الفصول بما يسمى بالربيع
والخريف والامتزاجيه هي التي تعيش داخل
الفصل الواحد يا صيف يشتاق وخلال هذه
الايام نعيش مرحله انتقاليه بين الشتاء
البارد والصيف الحار بما يسمى بالربيع ولا
يغرك دف الربيع ففيه موجه برد قادمه
يسميها العامه برد بياع الخبل عباته الم
ترى ان العقل زين لاهله ولكن تمام العقل
طول
التجارب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وخلال المواسم الانتقاليه تحصل فيه تقلبات
جويه حاده خاصه في موسم الربيع ليش لان
الصيف لا يولد الا بتعسر ويتمثل هذا
التغير بارتفاع وانخفاض في درجات الحراره
وامطار متفرقه بين ان واخر وغبار واتربه
منقوله ومستنكر شيبا قبيل اوانه اقول له
هذا غبار
الوقائعي
[موسيقى]